après le décès de cédric joue via lors
de son interpellation j'avais rencontré
sa famille et je vais arriver annoncé la
création d'une mission conjointe entre
police et gendarmerie pour passer en
revue nos méthodes d'interpellation et
leurs risques pour qu'un tel drame ne
puisse plus survenir
la police française ce n'est pas la
police américaine
mais des questions légitimes se poser
après plusieurs mois de travail
la mission a pu me rendre ses
conclusions et j'ai décidé de prendre
des mesures car personne ne doit risquer
sa vie lors d'une interpellation
la méthode de la prise par le cou dit de
l'étranglement sera abandonnée et ne
sera plus enseignée dans les écoles de
police et de gendarmerie
c'est une méthode qui comportait des
dangers par ailleurs si un policier ou
un gendarme doit maintenir quelqu'un au
sol lors de son interpellation il sera
désormais interdit de s'appuyer sur sa
nuque ou son coup